[Music]
we are anxiously awaiting descendants
three and a photo of Audrey's return has
us questioning if maybe this good girl
has gone bad
watch until the end to see what fans and
the movie stars think this next story
will be about if this is your first time
visiting the things don't break it to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up here's descendants 3 has
Audrey gone bad used at the end of both
movies the line you didn't think this
was the end of the story did you
signaled an upcoming movie in the first
dissonance movie which premiered on
Disney Channel in 2015 mouths green eyes
flicker as she delivers the prophetic
line in the last scene of descendants to
a movie which ranked as the second
most-watched movie on the Disney Channel
Lula delivers the same line while still
feeling defeated and angry according to
the cast the line wasn't in the original
script but was added at the last minute
when it was confirmed that dissonance 3
will air in 2019 both fans and the
movies cast went wild
we've been waiting to see what lies
ahead for the VK crew and it seems that
now who will get to find out there are
bound to be some surprises including the
potential return of mouths unknown
father based on the teaser trailer a
return were equally excited for is
Audrey played by Sarah Jeffery who was
referenced in the sequel but did not
appear a picture's worth a thousand
words
Sarah Jeffries returned as Audrey is a
welcome surprise as her character was
excluded in the second movie though
Audrey was mentioned she never made an
appearance it seems that we're in for a
crazy comeback as a picture of Audrey
and Chad charming played by didn't die a
good care hit the internet we are shown
a very different side of Audrey as she
seems to have shaved in her good girl
bubblegum pink style for a villains
outfit complete with maleficent scepter
that is topped with a glowing green
jewel she's even changed her hair to a
mal surprise
pink and purple look with her head
tilted back in a cackle juxtaposed with
Todd's look of innocent kin
earn it seems like Audrey might have
gone to the dark side the shot shows the
two at night and what seems like a force
and has the internet curious about what
might have led to this unexpected
moments villains return of mouths dad we
could speculate that Audrey will be the
new villain in descendants three but it
seems like that role is already being
filled by Cheyenne Jackson who will play
Hades from Hercules in the teaser
trailer the return of mouse dad is also
hinted at even dr. Faso Lear from
Princess and the Frog
and his daughter Celia played by Jada
Murray will make an appearance with
these potential villains stirring up
trouble where would an evil Audrey fit
in descendants - before we addressed
with Audrey's potential role in the
third movie is let's take a step back to
examine why she was excluded from the
sequel social media has been an
important component of marketing the
movies with each star eager to post
updates of their experience and
gratitude for their loyal fans there was
a stir when Sarah Jeffery was not
involved in the second movie and she
took to Twitter to clarify that her
absence was because of a scheduling
conflict while she was working on her
NBC series shades of blue now that she's
back for the third movie Jeffery can't
resist but share her excitement on
Twitter saying that already on the first
day of shooting
she was predicting that fans will flip
Jeffery even shared that she was shook
Jeffrey's excitement is contagious but
cryptic it's clear that she's keeping
something secret for us and she hasn't
commented on her evil look at all social
media reactions
social media theories can take you down
a crazy rabbit hole of anticipation a
post by axe echo underscore reacts on
Instagram speculates that maybe Audrey's
portraying Maleficent in a play and
makes a comment or tell the story about
Mao's father that offends mal this is
then connected to the trailer as an
explanation for why mal might be
inspired to find her father meanwhile on
Twitter fans are wondering if audrey has
been possessed by Maleficent and Chad
doesn't know explaining the surprise and
terrified look on his face in the
picture this theory does make sense when
to the history of these characters from
Sleeping Beauty and previous descendants
movies as far as the original Disney
fairy tale Maleficent and Princess
Aurora do have a relationship and
history and the curse comes from
Maleficent need for revenge from feeling
rejected by the family it's possible
then that Audrey and Maleficent would
possess some kind of bond and
understanding in the descendants
universe plus mouth fails elitism and
Audrey might be a viable option for
Maleficent to accomplish her goal of
destroying everyone on Oregon to teach
them a lesson for banishing the baddies
to the Isle of the Lost
since mal was able to enrage her good
side it should be equally as possible
for Audrey to embrace her dark side as
nanny Ike Hakeem also points out on
Instagram that the descendants book
series explained that if anyone touches
Maleficent staff they will be cursed for
a thousand years maybe in order to
circumvent this sleep
Audrey sacrifices her body and agency to
be taken over by Maleficent to
accomplish her evil work clues from the
cast and Ortega fans aren't the only
ones anticipating what descendants three
might have in store for us Doug Cameron
who plays now has some ideas for her
character Cameron loves that her
character has the power and the most
evil person combines with the heart of a
good human she hopes that the third
movie will show now becoming more of an
individual who can fight her own battles
and make the right choices
this could suggests a role reversal if
Cameron's hopes come true if we have a
villain using their powers for good
there's no reason we couldn't have a
hero using their strength for evil
Cameron voice has an idea for Carlos's
character too he's hoping for an epic
final kids vs. parents battle to end the
series maybe a good girl gone bad would
be the perfect catalyst for voices
dreams to come true the fact that there
are endless possibilities for the
direction of a character like Audrey who
was even absent from one of the movies
shows how well thought-out and executed
these stores are as they keep us coming
back for more do you think Audrey will
actually go bad by her own will or is it
only explainable by a portrayal of evil
or a possession and that's all for
descendants three
has Audrey gone bad if this is your
first time visiting the things don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up
[Music]